all right guys so let me just say off
the bat I am really sick and I went to
see this movie because hey this is what
I do I do this for you guys and I enjoy
doing it but just bear with me because
my voice is like it's gone killing them
softly stars Brad Pitt James Gandolfini
Richard Jenkins Ray Liotta a lot of
people are in this movie it's directed
by Andrew Dominik and he made the
assassination of Jesse James by the
Coward Robert Ford also starring Brad
Pitt Wow now I've said this in a few of
my reviews lately I have been trying to
avoid trailers for movies really really
hard I've been trying and I actually did
not watch one trailer for this film
going in and I didn't even know what the
plot was honestly I went into this movie
completely blind no knowledge whatsoever
I knew was the poster and that Brad Pitt
played a hit man I find that I enjoy
movies more that way without hyping
myself for something without going in
with some sort of expectations without
watching a trailer that is more than
likely misleading and going into a movie
and going wow that's not what I expected
or wow I wanted more action or there was
too much dialogue or something because I
saw the trailer and it made it look cool
I don't have to worry about that if I
don't watch the trailer so that's one of
the reasons I haven't been having as
many trailer reviews as Welli they know
you guys have wondered about that
basically Brad Pitt is a hit man in this
film and he is hired to kill these guys
who rob ray Liotta's card business they
robbed him it kind of went bad Brad Pitt
gets hired to take these guys out and he
goes around basically trying to figure
out how he can do that now that sounds
really interesting it could be great
right there could be a lot of really
intense scenes good dialogue but also a
fair amount of action and suspense and
although this movie has greatness in it
for sure there is some really great
scenes in this movie there's something a
little mixed up about it
see before I get into the first half of
this movie I want to say the last half
of this movie or better yet the last 30
minutes of this movie where what I
wanted the entire film to be like it was
intense it was darkly comical it had
great dialogue but it also had a really
good sense of action in it when I say
action I don't mean like transformers I
mean like good suspenseful building
scenes and the last 30 minutes of this
movie I thought were just fantastic and
it has one of the best ending lines of
the entire year it made me smile I loved
it however the
getting of this movie is really rocky
because you get introduced to so many
different characters it's a little
difficult to follow because honestly I
would say in the first 30 minutes of
this movie there's only one scene with
Brad Pitt you don't really get invested
in him as the main character he doesn't
really get to flow really into the last
half of the movie honestly that was a
little weird for me because I feel like
the movie didn't have progression you
know there wasn't someone to experience
the movie through it was hard to latch
onto the main character because you knew
so little about him and you were exposed
to him so minutely that by the time you
actually got to his character I was like
okay finally we can get going here the
performances are all out of this world
like everyone is great Richard Jenkins
of course is great he's always good Brad
Pitt really knocks it out of the park in
this movie I've honestly never seen him
give a bad performance now I haven't
seen some of his early 1990s television
work but let's just forget that happen
Brad Pitt's a great actor and here is
really good he plays a convincing hitman
and the scenes where he's like trying to
prove himself to people like this is a
great scene in a bar where he's talked
to the dude from Argo who was also
really good in this movie by the way and
he's very intimidating in this scene
he's like look dude and he gives him
like a little slap on the face and
everything it was great really good
acting Ray Liotta is also good in this
movie too there's one scene in the film
that I found a little too brutal and I
thought they went a little over the top
and was unnecessarily violent it just
felt like you know a little out of place
but this is a mob movie so you know
whatever see I like this movie overall I
did there was really good things in this
movie but there's just something about
the way the film was constructed that
was conflicting with itself because
there's a really heavy message in this
movie and for a long time it felt
political every mobster in this movie
constantly has like political debates on
the television it takes place during
2008 you see a lot of Barack Obama and
George Bush and you see all these people
going back and forth in the news and for
a long time I was like why are we
continuously going back to this it was
until the last scene in the movie where
it made sense to me and I understand
what it was therefore and I were
actually really appreciate that movie's
message although it is a little
heavy-handed I liked and I got it and I
understood what it was going for it's
just the first half the film felt
misdirected too many scenes with
characters that I felt didn't need to be
that long and it's not that the dialogue
was bad it's just that I felt like it
was unnecessary
sorry to be there and I wanted to get
back to Brad Pitt's story and what he
was doing and where he was going the
film looks great it has excellent
sequences in it but the last 30 minutes
of this movie are brilliant it's
fantastic and I wanted the whole film to
be like that the film has great
performance is it looks great some of
the dialogue is really well done the
chemistry between actors is excellent
you can tell there's a good director to
act a relationship here it's just the
first half of the film was not cohesive
with the second half in my opinion no
some people have been tweeting me like
hey I've been hearing this film is like
Drive or whatever I really found no
relation to drive at all in the movie
the only reason I think people might say
that is because they maybe watch the
trailer and thought there'd be more
action I can't really blame a film from
last year for that you know that's
that's marketing and that's why I don't
watch trailers and I suggest you do that
too honestly try it it helps I'm gonna
give killing them softly Abby I enjoyed
the film overall it just has problems
and there is greatness in there there's
greatness under there it's just it
didn't mesh if you guys want a hitman
movie that has a perfect amount of
dialogue and action and great
performances and direction all around I
suggest collateral this is actually one
of my favorite movies if you haven't
seen collateral please check it out an
oscar-nominated performance by Jamie
Foxx Michael Mann excellent hitman movie
definitely check this out thanks a lot
for watching guys and as always if you
like this and you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]